c'était il y à très très très longtemps
en ce temps là il y avait la terre d'à
côté de la terre il y avait les gy be
qui passaient tranquillement leur temps
à peindre la campagne il a chanté
de l'autre côté de la terre il y avait
des shadoks qui passaient leur temps à
guerroyer contre les arbres des petits
cailloux
[Musique]
et tout le monde apparemment il était
content
au début de notre feuilleton nous vous
l'avions promis des shadoks et des jib
il devait arriver sur la dette et bien
les y voilà
et notre histoire pourraient s'arrêter
quand dans les belles histoires on
finirait dans dix ans qu'ils furent
heureux et qu'ils des cures longtemps
mais ça serait vraiment trop abuser de
votre crédulité
car pour ne rien vous cacher c'est juste
au moment où notre feuilleton allait
s'arrêter
[Musique]
il est vrai en vêtements pour les uns
comme pour les autres allaient commencer
figurez vous qu'un jour les vaillants
shadoks s'apprêtait comme d'habitude à
livrer bataille à un ennemi très
supérieurs en nombre et il sonnait du
corps pour nettoyer et puis tout à coup
c'était la belle terrible beit qui en ce
temps-là régnait ce matin et les shadows
des imbéciles à l'avait réveillée elle
répondait la bête au joli nom de gégène
ou à n'importe quel autre nom d'ailleurs
mais en général il valait mieux pas
l'appeler quand on vous disait que les
vrais embêtements allait commencer vous
vous rendez bien compte que ce n'était
pas uniquement une façon de parler
alors notre histoire finira plus tôt
comme ceci
c'était il ya très très très longtemps
en ce temps là il y avait la terre d'un
côté de la terre il y avait les jbe de
l'autre côté de la terre il y avait les
shadoks
entre les deux il y avait gégène la bête
qui les embêter et j'adore qu'il est
gibily revient au bout d'un certain
temps ne pourrais pas vivre longtemps
sur une terre dès qu'un gène comme ça
alors ils décidèrent les uns et les
autres d'aller sur la lune qui n'avaient
pas de gégène du tout
[Musique]